[Music]
we don't talk about bruno huh well too
bad cause i am gonna talk about bruno oh
yeah you heard that one right i'm gonna
talk all about bruno and there's nothing
you can do to stop me from talking about
bruno
[Music]
it's cool dude yeah overall he's a nice
fella
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that knows you've got a gift
for smashing that subscribe button we
may not talk about bruno around here but
today we are talking about disney's in
kanto because this thing it's just great
every song is a banger the animation is
beautiful and stephanie biatris i mean
what more can i say other than 99. i
legitimately loved this movie after
getting sort of missed in theaters back
when things were slow with reopening
this one has blown up over recent weeks
on disney plus streaming and it's easy
to see why it's fun it's clever it's
heartfelt and most of all it's different
from pretty much every other animated
movie that's been put out in recent
years but maybe the most different thing
of all is that this is a movie filled
with unsolved mysteries not in the sense
of like hey they forgot something or
well that's clearly a teaser for encanto
ii encanto mas duro but more like the
films just saying hey the characters
finish their emotional and spiritual
journey but some of the unexplained
things of this universe yeah we're just
gonna let them stay unexplained come to
your own conclusions and a quick search
over any discussion of encanto on the
internet clearly shows people are
definitely trying to do just that so how
can we not get in on that action
ourselves by diving into the biggest
question that remains at the end of this
movie does mirabel finally get to move
out of the nursery seriously just
because she didn't get a magic door
doesn't mean a grown woman should be
forced to sleep on a janky nursery cod
meanwhile you got this kid over here
going hey look i'm tarzan it's my
literal jungle room watch me cuddle with
a capybara the madrigals have some
severe issues with the haves and
have-nots in this movie but all of this
is just a byproduct of the real
questions that are being asked here what
is mirabelle's gift does she get a gift
like ever i mean sure the whole premise
of the movie is that she doesn't get one
but was that really true or is her gift
something lame like the gift was the
friends we made along the way well i
think i have the definitive answer i
know for sure what mirabelle's gift is
when she gets it and what it means for
the rest of the family but in order to
get there we have to cover some deeply
hidden easter eggs as well as a few
other theories about how the magic of
this world actually works so listen up
dolores this one is for you all right
since the setup here actually does have
a lot of moving parts that play into
today's theory it's probably best to
recap things for quick reference encanto
takes place in colombia near the
beginning of the 20th century sometime
after the thousand days war a civil war
between two rival political factions the
encanto of the title refers to the
charmed place between two mountains
where a community of refugees and their
descendants live under the protection of
the magical madrigals a family blessed
by a miracle that gives each of them a
superpower when they come of age peppa
can control the weather with her
feelings julieta's cooking can heal
luisa has super strength isabella has
phytokinesis which is the power to
control plants camilo is a shapeshifter
antonio can talk to animals dolores has
super hearing and bruno
can see into the future the miracle also
made their house casita come to life the
miracle appears to be contained inside
of a magic candle protected by the head
of the family abuela alma who led the
community to the area after her husband
pedro died while on the run from enemy
soldiers but in the least subtle disney
metaphor since elsa was birthed out of
the yannick ice luge of mommy issues in
frozen two there are literal and
figurative cracks forming and it all
leads back to our main character
mirabelle the only madrigal who on the
appointed day was not bestowed with a
gift or special magic room by the
miracle candle and no one quite
understands why so with the rest of the
family's magic fading mirabelle sets off
to solve the mystery by visiting each
member one by one in a structure that
feels like it was ripped straight out of
a mega man game one therapeutic musical
boss fight at a time she learns that the
pressure everyone is under is what's
causing tension within the family one by
one they all heal and come to a new
understanding of each other except for
abuela alma who won't hear any of it a
few musical numbers and one heartfelt
confession later the community comes
together to rebuild casita and the
encanto is renewed in a new more open
and more powerful form bien esta lo que
bien acaba well except for the fact that
the candle went out and stayed out and
we never truly found out what made
everything work in this universe we also
never get confirmation about whether or
not mirabelle in the newly rebuilt
casita gets a magic power or magic room
and working those questions out is
what's driving a lot of the post-movie
discourse so are the answers actually
here in the film or is this just a case
where it's like you gotta make up your
own personal head canon well i think i
have all the answers but you have to
look really closely at the clues that
are sprinkled throughout the movie first
and foremost let's debunk a theory that
i've seen tossed around on the internet
it's actually one that a member of our
team first pitched out to me the magic
of the house and even the miracle of the
candle are all thanks to the spirit of
the late abuelo pedro the grandfather
who's still watching and protecting the
family even after his tragic death gotta
admit on my first watch of the movie i
was waiting for this to become the big
twist an emotional reunion of loved ones
that brings the family together and
revives the magic of the house and then
it just didn't come i no surprise but in
retrospect it also kind of makes sense
for one thing while casita does seem to
have a mind of its own as if it were
inhabited by a friendly spirit the
structure's very name being referred to
in the spanish language feminine form
casita seems to indicate that the
madrigals don't regard the presence
itself as that of a man and while it's
also a very plausible theory that
pedro's spirit might have resided inside
the candle this ultimately gets debunked
when magic returns to the house at the
end of the movie but the candle does not
return with it this suggests that the
magic of the house is coming from
somewhere or something other than the
candle but where well let's look at the
doors they are unquestionably the most
important magical symbol within the
movie mirabelle obviously doesn't get
one setting her apart from everyone else
but there's another key difference here
that everyone seems to overlook here are
all the doors notice anything
interesting anything unusual antonio's
is different when every other family
member visited abuela alma in the magic
candle to receive their doors the image
on it featured their adult selves but
antonio's door is the first one to
depict him as an actual child it's an
interesting detail it's also worth
pointing out that this happens after he
requests mirabelle to be the one at his
side during the ritual could those two
events possibly be connected well the
timeline definitely seems to support
that sort of conclusion abuela alma
ushers in all the adult doors up until
mirabelle mirabelle as a child gets
nothing and then in the immediate next
ceremony for antonio he gets a new type
of door a kid door while under the
guidance of mirabelle basically it seems
what we're seeing here is a handover
from abuela alma as the keeper of the
encanto to mirabelle who's now in charge
of keeping that miracle alive for the
next generations that is why antonio's
door is different it also explains
mirabelle's gift she and abuela alma
have the same gift they're both the
keepers of the magic a magic that comes
not from a deceased relative but rather
from a devotion to family and a devotion
to service we were given a miracle
because of you we learn in the movie's
conclusion that abuela alma first
manifested the miracle as a defensive
reaction to trauma and extreme grief she
needed to protect herself her three
infant children and her community from
violent soldiers and as a result she
gave birth to a literal fortress she
gave rise to a family of powerful
protectors and she pushes them hard to
serve the community i was given a
miracle and i was so afraid to lose it
that i lost sight of who our miracle was
for as someone who is always most
concerned with expectations of the
future and what her family could achieve
and become the doors showed adult ideals
that the family had to aspire to but the
door that mirabelle conjures for antonio
depicts her main concern that antonio is
happy and confident with himself now ask
yourself this what is abuela alma's
power none that we know of she's just
the leader the one that holds the family
together the one in charge of protecting
the candle even abuela's magic room
reflects this devotion to the family we
don't see much of it but small details
like the top of the window frame and the
tiles on the ground in her bedroom match
the room that she shared with abuelo
pedro it's a copy of the home that she
shared with him here we have this house
that's able to make magical jungles and
giant gardens but abuela's room is a
symbol of family so what is mirabelle
well she's the same thing she's the
family's cheerleader the one who uplifts
everyone around her she is the focal
point that is grounded in family for
proof of this just look at her character
design each of the powered madrigals
have a symbol for their respective gifts
incorporated into their clothing like
some sort of superhero logo a stylized
hourglass for the future seeing bruno
the chameleon for the shapeshifter
camilo an assortment of animals on
antonio's vest sound waves around
dolores's collar barbells on the hem of
luisa's dress isabella's flower
embroidery a mortar on julieta's apron
even abuela alma's house dress has a
stylized representation of the mountains
that protect encanto's valley now look
at mirabelle's dress she has elements of
all of them antonio's animals luisa's
weights isabella's flowers a basket of
rolls for julieta a rainclown for peppa
music notes for dolores camilo's
chameleon she brings all of them
together she's the one that quite
literally holds the household together
just like alma has done up to this point
but there's one other design detail here
that the animators included to
communicate this the motif of
butterflies butterflies are everywhere
on mirabelle's dress which directly
connects her to the design on the magic
candle but what you might not have
noticed is that it also connects her
back to the casita and abuela alma we
see that the back wall of the kitchen
the heart of the casita has the repeated
theme of butterflies and on abuela
alma's dress just below the mountains is
a lining decorated with butterflies this
is probably why both mirabelle and
abuela alma are the only two that we see
actively talking to and controlling
casita well i'm sure anyone in the
family can possibly do it these are the
only two that the movie actively shows
us affecting the actions of the house
further supporting the connection
between the two women these women are
one and the same mirabelle has no power
because well now her power is protecting
the magic she has risen to take over the
family miracle moving forward the movie
outright tells us this except you know
none of us notice because it tells us
this in spanish during the climax when
abuela confesses the story of finding
the miracle a spanish ballad plays in
the background dos orguitas or two
caterpillars caterpillars as in the
creature that ultimately metamorphoses
into butterflies could this possibly
relate to the two women in the movie who
symbolically transform into butterflies
and wear them all over their clothes
well the lyrics go a little something
like this eye little caterpillars don't
hold on anymore you must grow apart and
return you'll keep moving forwards two
women who grow apart only to grow back
together and move forward huh sounds a
lot like the relationship between
mirabel and alma and how their emotional
separation ultimately moves the family
forward into a new era of empathy and
emotional understanding quote again from
the translated lyrics you must leave and
build your own future two disoriented
caterpillars and two well-wrapped
cocoons with new dreams now all that's
missing is to do what's necessary in a
world that keeps changing taking down
its walls there comes our miracle i mean
it's all right there guys like a
strategy guide for solving the family's
problems the world has changed so take
down the walls and rebuild come out of
your protective cocoons and embrace each
other mirabelle's gift just like alma's
is to feel what others need and in the
case of her family see their potential
and help him realize it but alma
ultimately lost her way she pushed the
family too hard she held on to them too
rigidly because she was still trapped in
the past a time that she needed to be on
the defensive but as the song said times
had changed they needed to rebuild in
order to move forward and so it seemed
time for the miracle to be passed on to
the person whose name is literally one
letter off from the word miracle cause
let's face it friends sometimes the
clues don't have to be all that subtle
but hey that's just a theory a film
theory and cuts
you